oh goopy goopy gwen hey everyone i'm
abby sharp
welcome back to abby's kitchen
today's video is sponsored by
squarespace and we are back with another
bizarre celebrity what i eat a day
review
this time i'm going to be reviewing none
other than the queen of
pseudo wellness science gwyneth paltrow
love her hater love to hate her whatever
your stance
you probably are well aware of gweny's
status
in the health and wellness space largely
as a result of her controversial
wellness brand
goop this will actually not be the first
time that i've discussed goop on the
channel so if you want to see
what i have to say about the goop detox
diet and products
you can watch that right here but today
we'll be taking a look specifically
at her harper's bazaar food diaries
video so
get your diet culture bingo cards ready
there's a lot to unpack
and of course before we do a quick note
about my sponsor
who you've heard me talk about all the
time because i'm such a huge fan
so if you're not familiar with
squarespace
it's an all-in-one platform to run your
business whether you're looking to
build like a website or blog an online
store
or use their marketing tools and
analytics
you guys know that between youtube and
my blog and public appearances and
parenting two boys
under three in a pandemic i have no
patience for technology
so squarespace is amazing because it
takes care of the seo
and site management for people who are
busy juggling things like
business and family and when everything
in your digital presence
works together it just makes it so much
easier
for you to focus on your actual business
so you can check out squarespace.com for
a free trial
and when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com
abby sharp to save 10 off your first
purchase of a website or domain
and super quick before we dive in you
can pause the screen
or check out the description to check
out my disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
with current
or previous experiences with disordered
eating or eating disorders
we will be using a lot of diet culturey
language here and also evaluating meals
based on their nutritional merit alone
which
ultimately says very little about their
overall value
it's also worth me just saying that this
format follows a celebrity's description
of what they eat
it ultimately tells me very little about
its accuracy
portions brands cooking preparation etc
not to mention their overall
relationship with food so
take this more as general education to
the masses
not specific recommendations to gwyneth
and of course don't forget to subscribe
to this channel and
ring that little bell so that you never
miss out on a video
all right let's get into it
first thing i do when i wake up is oil
pulling with coconut oil so i have raw
organic coconut oil
i put some a spoonful in my mouth while
i'm opening curtains and everything
i'm sort of swishing it around all right
let's talk about this oil pulling
while opening curtains uh essentially
gwyneth claims swishing a tablespoon of
oil around her mouth for about 10 to 20
minutes
and spitting it out helps kill bacteria
in her mouth
now there is actually some research to
suggest that oil pulling can provide
some benefits for oral hygiene so for
example
one 2016 randomized control trial found
that
oil pulling with coconut oil for about
10 minutes every day
helped to significantly reduce bacteria
responsible for plaque buildup
in as little as just two weeks while
some
other research suggests that it may also
help to reduce bad breath
oil pulling with sesame oil has actually
also been shown to be
as effective as mouthwash against
gingivitis
while other research has found similar
outcomes with coconut oil
so all of these oral hygiene benefits
are likely due to the higher amounts of
lauric acid
in coconut oil since lauric acid does
have some antimicrobial properties
however there is no evidence that oil
pulling can whiten teeth
or detox the body just in case you see
some of
those claims floating around as well
it's also important to note that the
studies that i did cite just now
have all been done with relatively very
small sample sizes
and found no major differences between
oil pulling and
mouthwash when it comes to oral hygiene
there also doesn't appear to be much
difference between the type of oil used
but i imagine that coconut oil has
become really popular for oil pulling
as it does have a more pleasant flavor
compared to other oils
not sure i'd want to be tasting like a
ton of sesame
first thing in the morning but also
coconut oil is just trendy in general
so ultimately whether you want to opt
for mouthwash or for a more expensive
option
like extra virgin raw coconut oil like
gwyneth
the benefits are virtually the same but
what she has said
is not wrong let's move on
i'm not a big breakfast person i'll eat
brunch sometimes late on a weekend
after i take my kids to school i go
straight to the gym and i always have a
big thing of water at the gym and i put
two of our
goop glows in there okay so other than
the occasional weekend brunch
gwyneth really isn't a breakfast person
it sounds like and that's cool with me
i mean if eating your first meal a
little bit later on in the day versus
first thing in the morning
better lines with your natural hunger
cues then listen to your body
and you do you however she has also been
on the record to say that the reason she
skips breakfast
isn't so much because she isn't hungry
in the morning but rather so that her
energy levels don't
peak and valley throughout the day um
interesting so it's totally normal to
see ups and downs in our energy levels
throughout the day
this is actually one of the ways that
our body communicates to us
that it's time to eat but if we want to
minimize the roller coaster
and deliver a more steady stream of
energy
we actually want to focus on meal
frequency and
quality not skipping or delaying a meal
i mean when we skip a meal what happens
two
apple fritters sliver of pecan pie
large fries with gravy and bacon
well we risk letting ourselves get
ravenously hungry
which may send us rushing to the kitchen
for some kind of high energy aka
high sugar snack and that likely isn't
going to keep us full for very long
perpetuating the vicious cycle so
if we want to avoid those peaks and
valleys and get off the energy roller
coaster
it's actually best to eat regularly and
not let yourself get too
hungry now if her comment is in
reference to intermittent fasting's
alleged benefits for blood sugar
management
know that the research that we do have
showing some benefits
on insulin levels and fasting blood
sugars has been largely done on people
with type 2 diabetes
it's also shown somewhat mixed results
with one study finding
that women's blood sugar control
actually worsened
after a 22 day long fasting protocol
i also just have to say that her
statement about energy peaks and valleys
i know kind of reminds me of a sentiment
that i hear from a lot of people
who are trying to manage their weight
when it comes to eating breakfast
tell me if you've thought to yourself
well
if i eat breakfast then my appetite's
going to get revved up for the rest of
the day
rather than staying dormant for as long
as i can hold off
my first bite of food ugh
diet culture news flash folks
that's actually a good thing it means
that your metabolism is
working and you've trained your body to
be more efficient
with handling more calories and more
nutrition
not that she said any of those things
but i just wanted to clear that up as
well but
anyway i really do not care if you're a
breakfast person or not
but if you are going to enjoy breakfast
and are looking for one that will keep
your energy levels even keeled for
longer aim to build a
balanced meal with protein healthy fats
and fiber rich carbs
you know the hunger crushing combination
but
what does gweny consume instead water of
course
very expensive water basically a big
bottle of water
flavored with two packets of goop glow
supplements
that sell for 60 usd a pack
of course got to get that product
plugged in somehow
but anyway i took a closer look at these
goop glow
packets and they are apparently
formulated with antioxidants like
vitamin c
and vitamin e to help stimulate collagen
production
in the skin and protect against
oxidative damage
two packets of goop glow provide only 20
calories
along with 13 times her recommended
daily dose of vitamin c
and three times her recommended vitamin
e
so unnecessary for somebody who
clearly eats a lot of nutrient-rich
foods as for whether or not supplements
like these
actually work well there is actually
some evidence to support the use of
antioxidants like vitamin c
and vitamin e for skin health for
example
one large study found that higher
intakes of vitamin c
was associated with a lower likelihood
of wrinkles
and dryness in the skin while another
study found that
when taken together vitamin c and
vitamin e
can actually help to reduce the risk of
sun damage however
you don't necessarily need to rely on a
supplement
for any of these benefits as obtaining
these vitamins from the diet
is just as beneficial and really not
that hard
also while vitamin c toxicity is rare
getting over 2 000 milligrams or more
so that's half of what's in her water
has been associated with symptoms like
nausea
diarrhea abdominal cramps and gi
distress for some people
meanwhile supplemental vitamin e intakes
at around 68 milligrams or higher
have actually been shown to increase the
risk of mortality
that's not far off from the 45
milligrams of supplemental vitamin e
she's getting daily from her goop water
alone
ugh goop water doesn't sound good
um but anyways let's check out her meal
and obviously it's also in liquid form
get a smoothie from somewhere so i try
to have a smoothie that has some
good fat and some protein and some fiber
so sometimes i'll have like a cacao and
almond butter smoothie with
some spinach and some protein powder
sometimes if i'm in a rush
i just eat these delicious peanut butter
protein bars so after workout you
definitely want a combination of carbs
to replenish glycogen stores
and protein to help with muscle repair
so although we are getting a solid
amount of protein from the protein
powder
and almond butter in this smoothie it's
a shame that this smoothie is so
low carb especially because there really
wasn't any energizing carbs
pre-workout either i have nothing
against smoothies i think they are
a great convenient on-the-go meal
but because they are pre-digested in the
blender
they do tend to be less satiating than a
meal
that you chew with all of those same
components
now with that said i would probably
suggest that rather than choosing
between the smoothie
and the peanut butter protein bar that
she mentioned
i would actually pair them together for
her first meal of the day
that would feel more like a convenient
healthy meal to me
than just like a protein rich snack if
i'm hungover
which does happen occasionally although
kind of vary occasionally at this point
then i try to eat something like
you know like an egg sandwich or
something that will sort of
help me through it you can always get an
iv too that's a very good
hangover trick ah
oh okay so there is actually
research to suggest that eating eggs
after a night out can help to reduce
some of the symptoms of a hangover
i actually talk all about the research
on popular hangover cures in my video
right here but to summarize eggs contain
the amino acid
cysteine which helps to eliminate a
toxic substance called
acetyl acetyl aldehyde acetyl ac
which helps to eliminate a toxic
substance called acetaldehyde
which is responsible for a lot of the
unpleasant hangover symptoms
so yeah your girl gweny is definitely on
something when it comes to
the egg sandwiches however you know i'm
gonna say something about the iv
therapy recommendation i mean of course
this is something she would suggest i'm
pretty sure
goop invented iv therapy bars but in
short
proponents of iv vitamin therapy claim
that it helps to rid the body of toxins
balance hormones make skin glow boosts
the immune system
and yes of course cure hangovers
they also suggest that it is more
effective than oral vitamins because it
gets into your system faster by going
straight into your bloodstream
through injection now i gotta say that's
not necessarily a good thing
because in that you're bypassing the
digestive tract
which houses the body's built-in
safeguards and filters
that really do help to keep us healthy
and safe and considering there is no
real research to back up the efficacy of
iv
vitamin therapy and it isn't even fda
approved
i would feel a little weary letting
somebody who isn't even a doctor dump a
bag of vitamins
into my veins i know that vitamins and
minerals are
natural substances but they're actually
not benign
there's also very little evidence on how
an iv infusion
may compare to getting your vitamins in
capsule form however unless you're
actually deficient you likely don't need
to get it into your system
that much faster and if there is a
benefit to it for the otherwise healthy
population
it's actually likely largely the placebo
effect
for example one study found that both
the iv therapy group
and the placebo group felt better after
they had the
treatment when compared to baseline i
mean
i would want to believe that i was doing
something too if i was spending 100
or more per poke now despite no real
evidence to back up
its claims and the hefty price tag iv
vitamin therapy
also comes with its own set of risks
like bruising
inflammation of the vein and bleeding we
also need to consider that taking an
excess of vitamins
is not necessarily better and can have
adverse effects if administered beyond
their tolerable limits
so for example getting too much vitamin
a could put one at risk of liver damage
it's also important to note that those
with a history of kidney disease
high blood pressure or heart disease
should especially avoid iv
vitamin therapy as they are already at
risk of dangerous fluid overload
so yeah if you are generally healthy and
i get the sense that gwyneth is in
pretty good health
you're better off sticking with your
oral multivitamins
hydrating and eating a nutritious meal
after a big night on the town
or just do as i do and like go to bed at
8pm because
like gwen says in this video i'm too old
for that crap
next i'm usually eating for lunch stuff
that you would see on the goop website
like
a salad with some protein or you know
they're using jicama for taco shells
you know they'll do like a really clean
version of a turkey burger
oh yeah i was waiting to hear the words
clean or detox in this interview
somewhere
she didn't disappoint yeah
anyways so gwyneth mentions a few
examples of
clean goop approved meals that she eats
like a taco made with jicama instead of
a tortilla or a burger made with a
lettuce bun
so after her morning ritual and her
smoothie
i'm kind of getting the sense that
gwyneth likes to keep things pretty low
carb and hey like i've always said if
eating less carbs
feels good to you amazing but can we
please just throw
clean and detox out of our vocabularies
already
and start describing food for what it
really is
like maybe that jicama is super crunchy
or the lettuce is refreshing
and that's what she truly craves can we
focus on its
absolute true virtues not the assumption
that abstaining from some white carb
element
makes it an inherently cleaner choice
now obviously both of these do sound
like tasty nutritious meals as does the
salad with protein she mentioned
i really can't falter much on that other
than the fact that maybe they could use
some carbs
but i just feel that they would be so
much more emotionally satisfying
without the side of diet culture anyway
let's move on to snacks
i'll hit the snack cupboard at the goop
office
maybe i'll have some cashews or pretzels
or something like that
but i usually need something salty and
crunchy in the afternoon and then i'll
usually have a cup of green tea with
that and then that will hold me
through till dinner finally we got some
carbs going on
so these are some snacks that i can
definitely get excited about as we've
got a nice balance of protein and fat
in the nuts to pair with the carbs in
the pretzels
now you know i always talk about not
having naked carbs
and this would be a really great way to
satisfy those mid afternoon
salty carb cravings while making the
snack more
satisfying and satiating i also really
appreciate the way that gweneth
describes these snacks in more
tangible sensual terms you know they're
salty
and they're crunchy and that's what her
body craves
yum two thumbs up let's take a look at
dinner
my kids love asian food so we'll have
some kind of
asian fish noodles on the side my
daughter's vegetarian so we always have
one kind of vegetarian entree you know
one pot dinners are great on the goop
website a bunch we developed a bunch of
one
pot dinners so those are really great
for weeknights as well
okay so i have to agree with gwyneth
here that
one pot dinners are life not only
are they a quick and easy way to get
dinner on the table
super fast but they are also generally
low mass which is
so key for us busy moms i also get the
impression that her dinner meals are a
little bit more on the flexible side
maybe because there's something she
enjoys with her kids and hopefully she's
not putting her kids on a goop detox as
well
i mean carbs are so important for
growing kids
so contrary to the lower carb meals
earlier on in the day
we are getting a lot more balance with
this example of a meal so we've got some
protein the chicken she mentioned
and some fiber in the starchy root
vegetables or potatoes
so yay for more flexibility and balance
we try to eat early it depends on the
day but i like to eat dinner on the
early side i always feel
like i don't sleep very well if i go to
sleep very full so
i've gotten real geriatric about that
like
6 6 30 dinner time it feels good
so there is actually some research to
suggest that eating close to bedtime
can shift sleep patterns and delay the
onset of sleep
some studies have also shown that
consuming high glycemic index
carbohydrates in particular
may make it more difficult for us to
fall asleep quickly
however the same can be said for going
to bed hungry
as hunger pains can keep the brain alert
so it can be a bit of a delicate balance
so that's not to say that you can't eat
after 8 pm or whatever bogus diet rule
diet culture tells us these days
but you may have to experiment with your
own personal routine
to find a meal time and a bedtime that
best works for you so they're just a few
things
that i won't eat i
don't like dill i can't stand dill i
don't like to eat
baby mammals so i stay away from like
lamb and veal and
i don't eat octopus because they're
super smart
we don't agree on a lot of things
gwyneth but i definitely agree i don't
like dill
it sounds like she's pretty open to
eating a variety of types of foods
without any specific dietary
restrictions
the foods that she does avoid are things
like dill and lamb
veal and octopus are either due to a
taste preference
or ethical concerns rather than a belief
about them being
you know toxic or bad which is kind of
off-brand for her
but it does feel pretty refreshing to
hear and i hope that that's actually
true
cheat meal oh it's hard to name just
one cheat meal i love french fries which
is a well-known fact
and i love i do love pasta i really do
uh yes gotta chat about that cheat meal
and i get that this is a standard
harper's bizarre question but
i am waiting for an influencer to call
that out as bs and just say
hey nope no such thing as a cheat meal
anyways
harper's bazaar if you want to interview
me that's going to be my answer just so
you know
but anyway when it comes to gwyneth's
cheat meals gweny is apparently down
for all the carbs i mean namely fries
and pasta
is butter a carb i'm honestly not
surprised that she would exclusively
want to eat straight up carbs
considering they seem to be pretty
lacking in her day to day that's what
happens when we restrict folks
we want to eat all the things
i also find it pretty interesting that
gwyneth considers pasta to be
a cheat meal since there's tons of pasta
recipes on the goop website
and she often has aligned herself
professionally
with the infamous american chef mario
batali who specializes in
italian cuisine i guess i just find it
problematic when social media
influencers and celebrities
present themselves as having this fun
carefree healthy relationship with food
by aligning themselves with foodies and
chefs who are obviously
anti-diet culture and then claiming to
eat without explicit food rules
but then they turn around and capitalize
on an entire
brand focused around pseudoscience diet
rules
clean eating and privileged wellness
culture
oh that's just gwyneth who does that
right anyways in conclusion
while we don't have any information on
exact portion sizes
or what granite state a day actually
looks like when it comes to eating
at first blush this doesn't really seem
like a lot of food for a
busy and active business women like
gwyneth
we're mostly seeing a lot of liquids
lighter
low-carb meals supplements of course and
only
one really substantial and balanced meal
at the end of the day with her family
and who knows how much of it she
actually eats
all i can say is that i hope there are a
lot of potatoes
going on that plate but on that note
that is
all that i have for you guys today
another big thank you to squarespace for
sponsoring this video
also another reminder that this review
was not intended to critique gwyneth
personally or professionally
and i also understand that this short
harper's bizarre video
may not be an accurate representation of
how gwyneth regularly eats
but if you enjoyed this video and you
want to see me review more of these
harper's bizarre clips
please like it leave me a comment below
about who to check out next
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
you